i should have spelled it for him because
you know we're the spelling champions
wait a minute come back here
come back here what time it is
i think the rating is going to be a lot
higher next year when we take that [ __ ]
back
no y'all watch regardless like if
anything we watched we're going we got
the serena williams they never cared
before but now they're about to care
exactly and then they're going to lose
once we start caring we take over
something son
once
we took back golf yeah we gave it back
yeah and do not count soccer because
y'all whiffed this weekend for england
holy [ __ ]
i thought it was a black lives matter
protest when i was watching that thing
the whole time i'm like come on black
guy come on black guy
it was my question and france and france
and france
yeah yeah yeah yeah hey black suck it
soccer
yes oh real talk yeah because we're good
at sports
that's why so it's like we don't play
the kickball [ __ ] leave it leave it
today
running around getting heart attacks
from one of my favorite movies about
racial unity
white men can't jump sun even shines on
a dog's ass sometimes wow
wow you're gonna make fun of how stella
got her wait what's the movie where she
spells good
yeah yeah stella got a spell but it's
crazy shorty spelled better than akash
and hoops better than them too
oh yeah she's nice she hoops bro she
hoops she's nice
i ever have a spelling bee champion
she's nice at hoops i don't care if
she's better than me at hoops but she's
not trying
to spell and she got you stella mariah
on me bro huh spell mariah m-u-r-r-y-h
nope nope nope i made that wrong
wrong legend let your people down again
alex spell mariah
me and mariah go back like baby
yeah yeah there we go all right
now but how do you feel taking that
massive l nah she was an ill but we
could be all right
no no no no no you can't win them be
honest bro like let your racism fly
that [ __ ] hurt we're gonna be all right
huh if i'm being racist it's better a
black person than another asian
uh okay i like it
a white person uh-huh then i'd have been
competitively annoyed if it was another
like a chinese
i don't think chinese can spell
i don't know i don't think they can
spell it i assume they do well enough
though academically spelling i don't
think you could get a good scholarship
academically though that's our main
competition al's and ours might be a
little
bit english in their language like you
guys are learning english from a young
age
you go to india there are people there
that speak english but i'm just saying
academically
if they took spelling we'd be like oh
[ __ ] yeah black people
that's the least that's the least you
got nothing now all you got is that
little
fake baseball [ __ ] you play you all got
fake baseball all right baseball
all right yeah yeah
[Laughter]
wow he's amazing what happened just snap
at him next call him chaiwala chaiwala
can you get
he just called you chaiwala bro yo
have we told that story of the box i
don't know what we did it's just so
funny
god so you know bala says we're all
walking in and marcus is trying to like
tease val
a little bit right and we're just
walking into the studio and then
valla turns to me in front of mark and
he goes yo
should i just [ __ ] this guy up like
cause if mark had
no say in the matter as if he would just
have to stand there and [ __ ] paint
they get [ __ ] up
bala can you go valla could go oh he
could go he could go
oh yeah he looks scrappy he got it in
him
i can tell you can look at him
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] all right man well look this is
that was a long ass intro man we were
hoping for that to be like 10 minutes i
think we're 59 minutes into the podcast
but um
we got some [ __ ] to talk about it seems
like you're not trying to dig into your
loss in this spelling bee bro
yeah having a french girl not you guys
that's your favorite yo chill out
challenge what show she's friends
she's she's friends she's friends her
name is avant-garde
she's as french as marcus french yeah
we're french dogs that's how friendships
we're friends no she just got a french
name but she's not friends with
appropriate french names though you got
a lot of pairs yeah okay we'll take that
is that her name yeah i mean they got
some fire names i'll give him that